for years local police have worked to
stop thieves from taking catalytic
converters off of cars but the trend is
still a big problem a church in the
southwest valley is the latest target
now they can't properly serve the
community madison kimbrough talked with
staff to find out what happened if you
think your vehicles are safe in a
parking garage or gated parking lot like
this think again as the desire for
catalytic converters keeps on growing
for places like life transformation
church in henderson this is the second
time in a nine-month span that they've
seen their catalytic converter stolen
from their van where second catalytic
converter
was
was taken
and you know it's not cheap you know you
put those in you got upwards to a couple
thousand dollars so we're without a
catalytic converter but we've got a vent
and we've got a community who we'd like
to be able to serve the van is used for
their feeding distribution program along
with a way to transport the elderly
founding member sequette williams says
the expense alone in replacing the part
is causing concern as insurance won't
cover the loss the money that we have to
spend
to replace the carolina converter every
dime that we have to spend
it takes away from the programs
the first incident happened back in
january after they left their van parked
in the church parking lot but the second
time happened recently while it was
parked at what they thought was a much
more secure location the u-haul just
across the way we were hoping that it
would be behind you know sort of the
gates and the fence and security we got
hit a second time according to pastor
tibbs their truck was one of many
vehicles over at the u-haul on college
in boulder that had parts stolen as for
security footage they're still waiting
to hear back from the company
that was madison kimbrough reporting to
protect your vehicle you can buy
security devices designed specifically
for that some are simply steel plates
that keep thieves from getting to that
converter